parks and recreation it just finished
what are you up to now what are you
doing you relaxing you working what are
you doing I am you know just keeping it
chill I don't understand your Street
lingo I'm working I don't know I've just
been in a really weird mental state
we've been in a weird mental state yeah
I keep finding these bites all over my
body
what like that one and I don't know
where they're coming from sorry you
actually do have a bike I did right
there I spend most of my days wondering
where these next don't stop doing that
oh my goodness
- bite stroker stroked my face any day
for you Conan well have you been to a
doctor I mean maybe you should get these
checked I think it's a spiritual problem
more than anything and what way is it a
spiritual problem well I don't know I
feel like if it's not a physical thing
it's like a evil manifestation of
spirits yeah karma mark yeah I also gave
myself two hickeys on my arm how did you
how did you do that
how did you do this you sucked on my arm
no weightless and I've been really
hormonal lately and I caught myself
yesterday singing a song out loud that
goes kill kill kill die die die
[Laughter]
[Applause]
you